[Musique]
c'est qu'il a process
à cet égard
et moi bisous bisous et moi et moi vise
le rôle d'ubs
c'est interdit et le régime qui est là
alors est-ce qu'elle ne fut pas où elle
est venue sur le parquet rien de super
vite sur le parc
les gens me connaissent et petit minois
non je crois qu'on en fait je vois mieux
sur lui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et co
oh
[Musique]
coc
m
et
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu veux prendre jouer
même si on est rien qu'est ce que tu
peux nous raconter la chose improbable
qu'on apprenait joseph robert sait qu'on
a un trou noir dengue s'est réveillé à
9h du mat venant de rejoindre parquet sa
bulle à l'histoire et je n'aime pas les
dettes
non là ça me fait beau mais donc je
tenais à te dire que je suis très
contente que tu te sois réveiller si tôt
ce matin pour mon anniversaire
bah bravo à toi de moi cette idée de
l'inviter au ont vaqué l'attraction là
on va faire les charts thébaux caen
s'apprête à faire le train de la mine
on a fait croire à dak que c'était le
train qui fait le tour du parc dans
lequel djokovic ou en fait on est en
train de la mine
c'est de capter son attention
[Musique]
ma faim
de fait c'est qui direction de l'hôtel
avant de se changer
et si le film quant à se [ __ ] à poil
au ray
si des petites infos exclut les
coulisses du tournage comme j'aime
regarder regardez regardez comme joël
commission beau regard des organismes au
plateau regardez le des
télécommunications là le réalisateur et
surtout ce qui est intolérable et son
format sa peine
[Musique]